hey guys this is andrew for
trainingsensors.com
so very quickly for those who don't know
me i'm a professional trader for five
years
and i'm using technical analysis a lot
to help me
during any of my trades so today i want
to make a quick technical analysis and
review of what happened this week
especially on the s p 500 let's get into
it
[Music]
so guys this week i was posting a lot of
stuff on my
instagram so please click on the link in
my
in the description of the video if you
want to get all this market
updates that i do daily and i was saying
at the end of the week
that we have reached on the s p 500 a
major
level which is 3 700 which is for me
a very nice short-term target for some
profit staking so some of you guys were
asking me so do you think that we're
gonna have a reversal
because there is still some very good
news to come in this market
and that uh this is bullish and that the
buyers are very confident
and so on and so forth that's true but
guys
let's make a quick uh overview of what
happened this week
so we had the vaccine news so one more
laboratory had very uh successful
results on the testing that they did
for the scorpio 19 vaccine we have
already moderna and pfizer that are
gonna
start selling those uh vaccines doses uh
before the year end even then if there
was some
cut in the production of pfizer whatever
the market just you know sold off and
then came back right away
so this is a bullish sign i agree we had
some news about the stimulus package in
the united
states that could come earlier than
expected we could have
around maybe one trillion a stimulus
package coming before
the year end so this is bullish we saw
the us dollar getting sold massively
you know you you saw that guys uh the
euro dollar is like 121 something like
this
and every currency uh against the dollar
was going
higher this week so this is as well very
good for the market
but guys don't you actually see
something that we often see in finance
and we have a saying about this it's by
the rumor
sell the news all right so this is
exactly what is happening
where is the vaccine there is no vaccine
this is a rumor about the vaccine
getting sold soon
of course it's true but what i'm saying
is that we are buying the fact the
market is forward-looking
we're buying the fact that we're gonna
have a vaccine soon
but guys when the vaccine is gonna come
maybe there's gonna be some
you know uh bad news to to to arrive in
the coming months and then the market
would be selling
because those news are coming so what
i'm saying is that yes this is still
bullish we expect some talks on the
stimulus package so this might push the
market higher
but technical analysis is already
showing us
a lot of reversal signs let's get into
it let's check out
what those are so this is the s p
500 chart let's go to the daily
time frame first so in the video i did
two weeks ago i was uh
explaining guys that i was bullish
because uh i was seeing here
five waves up so this is this are much
lows and
i was actually um identifying
this move as a fifth wave because the
resistance
at 35 20 level
got broken so i was bullish here i was
saying there is some upside to come
target 3700 37.50 right those are my
levels 3700 has been reached
now what do i see it has been reached
quite
early guys so basically uh my upward
sloping trend line
that is here that was actually uh acting
as resistance even before
is giving me 36.80 as a level for now so
it has been slightly
um bridged on the upside
but only one day so you know i think
that everything that is trading above
this trend land is good to sell guys
all right we're not gonna stay long
above here so of course what could
happen
is that we have some more move up i was
saying 37.50
as a target and this is still my target
but maybe a bit later
what i see right now if i go to the
hourly time frame
i see some very interesting things guys
so
let's analyze this last move up which
was my fifth wave
because once again i use idiot wave
principle
to know if the waves development of this
market
is about to end or not and when i see
five waves my answer is yes
and here i can count five waves one two
three four five
now the question is is this fifth wave
finished so let's
get into this one so remove this
and i'm just gonna focus on what is
happening here guys
all right so this is uh the past two
weeks
so we had a nice move up and what i see
is that this actually is a wedge pattern
all right so when you have two trend
lines converging in the same
uh points so this is called a wedge
pattern usually
when you have a wedge pattern this is
the final move of a bigger
degree of a larger degree wave and
usually
it predicts a correction all right so i
have one here
so as long as i'm training above the
support trend line of the switch pattern
which is right now
at 36.50 i remain bullish i have also
the moving average coming coming here
so i'm bullish above 36.50
but guys if you are long it's a nice uh
it's a nice level to take some profits
as well
as i said everything that is above 3 700
is good to sell for me
uh this week and what else do i see guys
something very interesting i have two
more very interesting things to show you
so i tried to do some idiot wave
principle inside
this fifth wave and what do i have guys
one two three four five
an ending diagonal why because the force
wave is entering
wave one territory this is showing
weakness for those who are interested to
understand
why an ending diagonal is showing
weakness and how i know this is an
ending diagonal
please click on the link in my
description and you're gonna receive a
free
video about illiot wave principle all
right guys and this is gonna explain to
you everything
that i know and everything that i use to
actually giving you
this analysis so this is
clearly an ending diagonal as wave 4 is
entering wave 1 territory as we just
said
and ending diagonals usually predict
some corrections
all right so how about we already two
information i reached 3 700.
so first sign i have an ending diagonal
in a wedge pattern
so two three signs and have one more
reversal
um signal that is given here by the
macd so it's a momentum indicator and
actually guys look what i have here
this is very nice to actually predict
some reversals this is called a
divergence
all right so divergence is a signal that
is coming when you have two opposite
information coming from a momentum
indicator
here the macd and the market itself so
look at this
between the 6th of november and last
friday
the market went from 36.50 to
3700 so it went higher so i put
this purple trendline here all right
that is going higher that is an upward
sloping trend line and look at the macd
the macd is going lower
all right the macd was trading at 50
here
and now it's trading at 12. so the macd
is going lower the market is getting
out of steam guys the sellers the power
the selling power is growing
and the buying power is diminishing so
this is actually
some um leading indicators that could
give you some reversal so yeah i have
one more reason to think that the flows
all right are gonna start to change this
week
so i'm not saying on monday but maybe
wednesday you know usually tuesday the
market likes to change
uh as well the direction so maybe we're
gonna have a bullish monday
and then tuesday wednesday the market is
gonna start to show some weakness and
watch out guys
as long as we trade above 36.50
no no need to panic but if we break this
guys
this is probably going lower probably to
the
uh my safety line is to this 3 500 now
it's just i extend
this trend line that was giving me here
that we are that was telling me here
that we are on the fifth wave
so if we break this all right so roughly
3 500
this is my major support here this is
telling me that actually we might be
correcting this whole move up
i don't think this is not my preferred
scenario let's be honest my preferred
scenario
as i said in the video that i made two
weeks ago is that the market is
just gonna push like you know grind
higher just push a bit higher
and maybe revert about january uh
something like this uh
deeper than but for now as long as we
stay above this uh support
line of my watch pattern i am bullish
and as long as we stay above the 3 500
level i would be in the uh risk and mode
by the dip all right guys so i hope this
video helped you to understand why i see
some reversal signs coming so once again
everything that is
above 3 700 i would be seller of it if i
want to take a short position i would
take it
if i break the wedge pattern with the
target around 3 500
all right so this is my view for the
coming week and maybe even in two weeks
because these
processes usually take some time but
yeah i i think that the market is about
to reverse soon
that's it for me thank you guys and once
again don't forget to trade with the
tight stop loss and stay close to sure
i'll see you guys